[Musique]
bonjour françois bayrou bonjour entre
2002 et 2012 avait été trois fois
candidat à la présidentielle là vous
voyez trois héros différent ou toujours
le même bayrou
on bat le temps ça change un peu des
choses quand même évidemment pas
exagérer mais oui ce trois souvenirs
différents moi je vous ai entendu dire
que une campagne présidentielle ça
ressemblait un peu à un voyage
initiatique il ya trois affiches trois
voyages je voulais vous poser trois
questions courtes pour trouver un
adjectif c'était quel est le voyage le
plus périlleux le plus instructif et
puis aussi le plus exaltant alors
qu'elle est la campagne le plus exaltant
que vous ayez mené que j'éclate ans et
2007 c'est celle qui est au milieu parce
qu'on aurait pu gagner
il s'en est fallu de da c'est peu d'une
hésitation
des choses et du destin et probablement
sans doute
que les temps n'étaient pas mûrs sk une
campagne qui vous a plus appris que les
autres ben la première m'a beaucoup
appris la première année on part dans
une situation qui est absolument
improbable on est entre deux et trois
dans le sondage et quand vous êtes entre
2 et 3% comme la marge d'erreur est de 2
on s'est même placé quelques uns la
beauté pour vous ça
c'était une plaisanterie avec mon équipe
et mes et mes proches et puis on a
réussi
à imposer une voie politique nouvelle
vous a été candidat pour la première
fois en 2010 la décision de vous
présenter à l'elysée vous avez su qu'on
vous seriez candidats je pense à partir
de 1999
en 99 nous avons présenté j'ai conduit
pour la première fois une liste
l'élection européenne
et
réaliser un score alors que personne n'y
croyait
et donc 7
au fond c'est là que s'est forgé cette
idée que mon idéal d'un centre
indépendant qui n'est obligé d'être ni
d'un côté ni de l'autre contrairement à
ce que l'on voulait à tout prix nous
nous assigner vous êtes bien 90 note que
c'était possible
on a on a trouvé en 99 que c'était
possible et donc et donc
7,7 élections de 2002 c'était au fond le
suffisamment audacieux pour imposer
cette voie politique nouvelle c'est à
dire en 2002 vous êtes le capitaine du
du navire udf alors c'est un parti qui a
été fondée autour de giscard soixante
dix huit vous avez conquis ce parti on
est devenus patrons en 98 ce que vous
avez besoin de ce d'être chef d'un parti
pour pouvoir est candidat oui
moi je suis attaché aux partis
politiques c'est pas seulement moi c'est
c'est la constitution c'est la
république qui considère dans sa
constitution que les partis politiques
sont nécessaires pour la démocratie
et oui je suis un militant j'ai adhéré
à la à la formation politique dont je
suis le président quand j'avais 20 ans
et je n'aurai donc gravi tous les
échelons et j'ai en effet suivi cette
cette marche là ce parcours comme disent
les latins
le cursus en europe je sais pas s'il ya
beaucoup d'honneur mais il ya la bourse
us agrégé de lettres classiques donc on
prend des leçons de latin volontiers
mais justement vous parlez des vingt ans
d'efforts vous avez fait pour construire
cette carrière puisqu'elle est frappant
c'est dans cette première campagne j'ai
l'impression que la bascule est presque
sur un coup du sort c'est à dire c'était
en avril 2002 vous êtes à strasbourg un
gamin cherche vous voler votre porte
voix vous vous en rendez compte voulu
coller une petite gifle vous étiez
filmer les besoins de votre campagne ont
dû être catastrophé ils ont dit tous ces
efforts 20 ans d'efforts pour pour finir
comme ça ils l'ont été et je l'étais
mais finalement c'est à tourner dans le
bon sens parce que les français se sont
reconnus dans cette comment je peux dire
autorité paternelle
parce que c'était paternel c'était pas
du tout c'était bête père de six enfants
ça peut aider aussi à mais je sais bien
qu'on écrit des histoires comme ça mais
c'est pas la vérité la vérité c'est que
ça a basculé donc on a passé selon temps
dans des situations catastrophiques du
point de vue des sondages et ça a
basculé en février
toutes les formations de
la majorité de l'époque se sont réunis
pour créer un parti uni grands partis
s'étaient l'ump tout le monde était
d'accord je raconte un peu sauf vous
mais quel courage ce jour là vous vous
êtes présenté seul devant toute la
droite pour leur dire je m'affranchis et
vous avez été élevé par toute la salle
j'ai dit voulait faire un parti parce
que vous dites que on pense tous la même
chose mais si on pense tous la même
chose c'est qu'on ne pense plus rien et
je suis absolument assurer vingt ans
après
delà de la solidité et de la vérité de
cette affirmation et c'est ce jour là
que ça a basculé parce que les
françaises sont dit tiens au fond ce
type y croit à quelque chose cherche pas
une place
il est
il a osé le leur dire et c'est très
souvent dans ces circonstances là que
bascule en tout cas la perception d'un
pays là on a vu effectivement vous avez
le courage de résister puisque vous avez
été les dire en face ceux qui n'étaient
pas d'accord mais dans l'épisode de cet
petit gym l'impression on à votre vraie
personnalité est apparu
au lieu de la caricature qu'on faisait
de vous on vous car la culture est un
guignol comme étant un peu bêta test
nous a fait souffrir ailleurs c'est
votre vraie personnalité café à paraître
cet incident n'aura oui 3 oui je
chacun et ce qu'ils aiment et moelleux
le fond de ce que je suis c'est père de
famille
ces
patriarches parfois de 6 des enfants si
c'est ça que j'aime le l'idée que que
contre 11 mai
et qu'on transmet
des choses profondes qui viennent de
loin et qui sont destinés aller loin et
qu on le transmet par une affection
savait bien ce qu'est l'affection des
enfants en maternelle et maternelle
l'égard des enfants et qui réciproque
quelquefois
cette chaîne de tendresse
qui transmet quelque chose et vous voyez
c'est le le double aspect
affectif et transmission et quand vous
étiez karake durée comme justement le
contraire de ça comme un horrible j'ai
entendu dire que vous vouliez arrêter la
politique arabe ce moment là je me suis
quand même curieux quelqu'un qui a
autant de brens c'est c'est extrêmement
difficile demandé à jospin par exemple
parce qu'il a eu à peu près la même
caricature guignard
vieillot il s'est plaint on le
ridiculise un pour sa mère oloron le on
le ridiculise est perpétuellement et
honnêtement tous ceux qui sont passés
au crible de cette dérision n'a aucun
qui puisse vous dire que au point de
renoncer à la qualité haut de renoncer
deux heures de temps pendant une nuit où
je m'étais infuser la totalité des
épisodes somme avait découragé mais
quand le quand l'aube est arrivé j'étais
déjà reparti en 2002 c
vous qui avez changé ou c'est le regard
des français sur vous qui a changé pour
cette première campagne dont c'est le
regard des français
vers des français vous savez bien le
cette idée de centre qui est si
importante pour moi vous savez il ya ya
une expression en latin que tout le
monde connaissait je veux dire medio
stat virtus on traduit virtu sourire
tous par vertu pas vrai ouvrir tout ça
veut dire le courage
est donc cette cette idée que c'est là
que se tient le courage quand vous
refusez de tomber dans un camp ou dans
un autre dans les simplismes des camps
et quand vous refusez de considérer ceux
qui ne sont pas de votre avis vous
refuser de les considérer comme des
ennemis c'est ça le centre et c'est ce
que vous avez établi pendant aux yeux
des français pour cette première
campagne oui c'est je pense que là
les français ont vu que ce que c'était
pas de de l'apparence que c'était parce
que c'était
suffisamment vrai pour qu'ils puissent y
attacher du crédit vous avez donc changé
c'est la deuxième campagne qui va
commencer vous êtes cette expérience la
première chose c'est juste la fiche
orange pour aix pourquoi choisir une
couleur dans sa orange à ce que je
voulais que nous ayons une couleur à
nous que le bleu était pris par la
droite que le rouge était plus par la
gauche que le blanc peut pas le prendre
en france parce que c'est les royalistes
et que que le jaune c'est mauvaise
impression parce que vous savez bien
dans le syndicalisme on dit que c'est de
très près et donc
laurent j'étais disponible en plus c'est
une couleur que ce grand courant
philosophique
social chrétien on va dire de l'or la
cfdt nous
ce grand courant là aiment beaucoup la
couleur orange c'est devenu la nôtre
très très tôt au milieu des années 90
bon alors part de cette deuxième
campagne c'était un lancement de
campagne que tout le monde a trouvé très
réussi donc c'est le gazon non regardez
un extrait je vous ai invités en cet
endroit que j'aime pour vous dire ceci
qui m'engage et qui va pour beaucoup
d'entre vous vous engagez aussi
je suis candidat à la présidence de la
république
vous êtes dans votre la région de votre
enfance le village à votre famille c'est
quoi c'est la volonté de voler le
pyrénées qui vous êtes c'est affirmer
votre identité
si on peut dire un mot de cette affiche
dont je trouve qu'elle était réussi je
trouve le slogan excellent le slogan
c'était la france de toutes nos forces
et ça voulait dire deux choses la
première
on aime la france de toutes nos forces
mais
on ne peut
construire la france qu'en unissant
toutes nos forces le double sens de ce
slogan alors en forme et est je trouve
excellent et donc je crois que tout ça a
participé il y avait un état de grâce
parce que les montées très très vite on
est monté jusqu'à rejoindre dans les
sondages ségolène royal et puis après
on va en parler mais moi ce que je
retiens c'est qu'au début de cette
campagne vous êtes encore dans le rôle
de l'outsider la première campagne
c'était face à jospin et chirac là c'est
pas saddam royal et et sarkozy mais et
l'impression que ce rôle d'outsider vous
êtes habitués en fait depuis longtemps
depuis avant la politique depuis tout
petit presse non oui c'est assez juste
mais j'ai choisi des chemins qui étaient
des chemins qui refusait de se mettre
dans dans les camps dominant
j'aurais pu un comme vous disiez choisir
avait toute une partie de l'udf qu'on
considérait comme naturellement de
droite il aurait suffi que
qu'on entre dans cette acceptation de
soumission aux soumissions sympathique
soumission avec des galons avec des
postes avec des titres avec des
avantages et des privilèges
mais il se trouve que je ne peux pas
supporter l'idée de soumission d'avoir à
cognac c'est exactement ça
moi je pensais à ça je me dis aussi par
rapport aux bas à l'envoi ou c'est le
village où vous êtes né donc vous êtes à
fils d'agriculteur dans les pyrénées ce
pas franchement ce contrôle en france
quand vous étiez enfant vous avez un
problème de bégaiement n'avait pas
toutes les qualités pour arriver à la
très grande carrière que vous avez fait
j'avais les qualités mais pas les
apparences je crois que j'avais les
qualités pour fonds de 2
peut pas faire ce peut pas entrer dans
cette vocation j'allais dire dans ce
métier c'est pas un métier mais
si on n'a pas au fond de soi quelque
chose de ces résistants l'envi de
convaincre et puis la capacité de
comprendre
avant les autres parce que le cette idée
de centre qui s'est imposée en 2017 nous
avons mis vingt ans à
la construire moi je pensais parce que
c'est ce village que vous avez choisi
pour présenter cette campagne jeu que
votre père louis a été acteur il a été
maire aussi le père de votre mère a lui
aussi été maire g chez les bayrou
londres est souvent parler politique à
la maison c'était parler que de ça oui
car les beaucoup de ça je vais vous dire
la vérité c'est pas exactement ça
ce que j'ai ressenti en premier et ça
fait écho à ce que vous indiquiez c'est
l'humiliation du milieu social dans
lequel j'étais né
dans lequel je suis né ça que j'ai
ressenti et s'ils ont cherché ma
première interview
en 1978 j'étais très très jeune je crois
à mixer en 77
g
j'ai 26 ans
ma première interview 10 à 10
je m'engage parce que je veux être le
porte parole de ceux qui n'ont pas la
parole le fait de prendre une revanche
ça il ya quelque chose de revanche
sociale à jeu moi j'ai jamais pensé que
les relations sociales étaient étaient
bisounours c'est
le le fond du fond si on remonte
beaucoup d'années en arrière
c'est ce que je suis là où on mesure là
par course et puisque vous parlez de
cette enfance d'être revanche le grand
moment de la campagne 2007 pendant mon
esprit en tout cas c'est ce d'énormes
meeting que vous avez fait à bercy avait
dix sept mille personnes on est dans un
état second et
vous y repensez à grasse jjp ont souvent
j'y pense souvent parce que c'est c'est
au nez dans l'enchaînement d'une
campagne il a pressé le le la presse au
sens qu'on est pressé que vous savez
j'écris mes disques ou moi même donc eu
tout ça sous entend de tout ça demande
beaucoup de travail et je m'en souviens
comme d'une dune galopade effréné que
alors que j'aurais dû m'arrêter pour
pour
en profiter et m'arrêter mon équipe et
de ma directrice de campagne un chef de
campagne et et marielle de sarnez elle
est morte aujourd'hui sont amortis ya
non et
je crois qu'elle sentait bien qu'on
était à un moment assez rare et que
peut-être ça durerait pas autant que les
contributions comme on dit chez moi
aussi longtemps que les impôts et
parfois les sportifs dans une grande
grande victoire ils disent qu au moment
de la victoire il se remet m'en mets
tous les efforts qu'ils ont dû accomplir
pour arriver à ce que vous avez ce genre
de sensations dans donc parce que je
suis pas au bout du chemin ah oui c'est
vrai peut-être quelque chose qui
voudraient c'd'accord a éprouvé et puis
donc on est dans une très grande réunion
c'est vraiment la pochette votre
parcours à ce moment là en tout cas est
ce que vous vous souvenez du la première
fois vous avez pris la parole dans une
réunion publique de politique oui dans
67 vous n'aviez donc 16 ans est vrai
pris la parole dans une réunion
politique d'andré labarrère à poux donc
qui étaient au milieu de ses partisans
déjà à séance extrêmement courageux mais
en plus vous aviez ces difficultés de
bégaiement mais d'où vous tirez la force
à 16 ans de ce à quoi je ne sais pas
mais c'est c'est absolument vrai alors
il faut il faut que vous vous remémorez
la situation andré labarrère c'est un
homme politique pour notre région
absolument majeur
chef du parti socialiste représentant du
parti socialiste député ministre maire
de pau
[Musique]
et il se présentait pour la première
fois et j'étais
su aller coûte jeu sa réunion
et j'avais 16 ans et à saison doute de
rien et j'avais 16 ans et j'étais bègue
veut utiliser moi c'était ça qui qui
mériteraient bloque tout le monde dans
cet exemple est là et je co je crois que
c'est qu'andré labarrère a été un peu
aussi ému alors vous dites d'où ça vient
c'est pas jeu
moi je crois qu'ils qui a des étoiles
qui a du destin
je pense même que tout le monde un
destin tous
souvent j'ai pensé salle la jeune femme
mère célibataire qui élève des enfants
tout seuls d'abord en faisant boulot
difficile quand elle n'est pas au
chômage c'est aussi un destin c'est
aussi quelqu'un qui qui trace sa voie
sculpte son avenir et l'avenir des
enfants et
oui je pense qu'il ya du destin je pense
qu'on est prêt destiné à quelque chose
c'est une manière de vous ôter le mérite
de vous dire vous n'avez vous n'y êtes
pour rien que c'est le destin qui nous a
donné une courage
oui bien sûr françois mitterrand j'ai
souvent lu qu il avait énormément
d'admiration pour la force de caractère
dont vous avez fait preuve pour vaincre
votre bécane même chemin
mitterrand était savez j'étais son
ministre
disait il est tellement convaincu de
bayrou est très fort qu'il est qu il est
sûr qu'à bayrou sera du président c'est
vrai ça a été dit par beaucoup de gens
par lui charasse a fait une grande date
ce qui était son confident a fait une
grande interview pour dire ça je crois
que oui je crois que c'était vous dit
qu'il avait même parcours que vous pas
tout à fait le même parce que sa
jeunesse était très à droite la mienne a
toujours été là j'ai pas changé de deux
voix politiques mais françois mitterrand
je pense qu'il a été oui il l'a il a dû
faire son chemin la force du poignet il
venait pas des milieux privilégiés
et on veut des plus que je n'en revenais
mais au fond de lui même y avait ça
avait constamment ce goût de la révolte
contre les puissants guinand dû
consentir aucun effort pour être là
j'étais son ministre j'étais son
opposant en même temps il était
extraordinairement gentil avec moi
traite d'abord c'était un moment il
allait mourir c'était un moment
extrêmement difficile
de sa maladie et de sa vie
et on avait de très longues
conversations sur ce sur ce sujet-là sûr
comme vous savez je
crois que les morts ne meurent pas donc
et ça nous faisait une harmonie quelque
chose d'un peu
chose d'un peu émouvant et d'un peu
profond alors qu'on était en désaccord
sion sur bien des choses politiques mais
les choses politiques en tout cas à ses
yeux c'était totalement secondaire
puisque il avait adopté l'une et l'autre
position
chaque fois
quasi jusqu'au bout vous disais que
c'est la campagne la plus exaltante
celle ci à un moment vous étiez donc au
coude à coude avec ségolène royal est
donc susceptible d'être qualifié au
second tour où tout le monde cette fois
ci vous donné gagnant face heures cosy
j'imagine que dans cette période là vous
avez cru que vous seriez installé à
l'elysée je vais vous raconter le
souvenir le plus frappant pour moi de
cette période
donc en quelques semaines les sondages
passe de 10
à 22
et 22 c'était la qualification
et j'étais à une terrasse de café je
prenais un café avec mon équipe et il
faisait soleil
et c'est le matin ou rtl je crois que
c'est airtel a sorti ce sondage là
j'ai reçu un sms mon portable tu es un
sms
d'une de mes filles qui est formidable
qui est médecin qui était jeune femme à
l'époque
et elle est encore aujourd'hui
elle avait écrit papa
s'il te plait pas trop vite
et tout d'un coup
vous mesurer ce que votre aventure
personnelle
créer de
[Musique]
d'angoise de peur jeu que vous aimez
mais chez vous ça devrait créer au
contraire de l'euphorie vous toucher
enfin dote du doigt ce que vous désirez
je vais vous dire c'est un trait de ma
personnalité chacun a la sienne je ne
suis pas souvent au flore hic les
béarnais c'est un peuple nostalgiques
de chaque fois qu'il m'arrive quelque
chose de
d'inattendu de magnifiques de
formidables de tout ce qu'on veut
chaque fois je pense à ceux qui ne sont
plus là j'ai perdu mon père très jeune
comme vous savez
c'était ce qui me précédaient c'était
des parcours de vie difficile parce que
paysan dans une exploitation qui faisait
dix hectares et qui ne nous appartenait
pas
vivre sur cette surface de terre
avec un foyer des enfants
il n'y avait pas de sous à la maison
chaque fois dans les succès dans les
jeux pense en effet à ces étapes qu'il a
fallu franchir et en même temps ça
n'altère en rien quelque chose qui est
aussi mais c'est celle en même temps
l'autre c'est que j'ai une assez
profonde joie de vivre oh ça va mal
j'ai pas de problème excessif quand ça
va très bien je me souviens en 2007 met
pas loin d'être élu donc on se dit qu'en
2012 braid prennent vous êtes pas dit ça
début de la campagne
si mais en même temps je connais c'est
toute la difficulté le mon opposition
avec nicolas sarkozy avait une position
très rude très dur
j'ai dit souvent j'ai écrit dans un
livre que je lui avais consacré
j'ai écrit
tout ce qu'il aime et pour moi
secondaire et tout ce que j'aime il
méprise
on aurait pu trouver
une manière de de s'accorder
parce que il parle naturellement la
langue de la droite et je parle
naturellement la langue du centre
on aurait pu trouver mais ça
sa vision des choses
était qu' il ne voulait pas d'égal
ça n'allait pas avec des mois je n'étais
pas supporté de ne pas être égal cela
dit vous n'avez pas été élu mais vous
avez dit que vous voteriez hollande donc
ça pouvait a sonné comme un appel
françois hollande est là est élu avec
51,6 les 1,6 pour cent c'est vous qui
lui avait donné sans doute on veut tous
ceux qui ont voté vous avez fait il ya
françois hollande oui absolument tout là
lorsque vous avez remarqué qu' il n'y a
pas eu beaucoup de de contrepartie c'est
ce que je me rendis c'est beaucoup mieux
au fond alors je trouve ça très très
un conséquent du point de vue politique
élu président de la république
grâce à grâce au choix ou avec le choix
de
quelqu'un qui était dans l'autre camp
et d'en tirer aucune conséquence j'avais
déjà vécu ça avec chirac
qu'en 2002 jacques chirac est élu
président de la république avec 80 % des
voix contre le pen je suis son premier
rendez vous le lundi matin et je lui dis
tu vas être élu président de la
république
faut savoir jacques chirac exiger qu on
le tutoie canton n'était pas de ses amis
ses doigts d'or encore plus complexe
qu'on ne croit ses amis le vouvoyait
alain juppé de vous voyez moi ils
exigeaient que je le tutoie c'était
c'était un peu subtils comme comme
personnalité et donc je lui dis tu vas
être élu avec 80 % des voix faut faire
un gouvernement d'union nationale
et il m'a dit tout ça c'est des
conneries je vais faire le parti unique
je dis bah j'en serais pas
il me dit bon ben on restera amis ce qui
veut dire je vais te faire la guerre à
mort
donc j'avais vécu exactement la même
chose je n'ai jamais compris ça ni dans
un cas ni dans l'autre leur rôle en divx
est pas de sa faute c'est la faute de
martine aubry qu
il ya quelque chose qui est plus vous
consoler ses on parle pas de la campagne
de 2010 tête puisque vous n'avez pas été
candidat mais
j'ai envie de dire c'est votre plus
belle victoire vous voyez vous qui avait
décidé l'élection permis l'élection de
l'un des magnats concassées ça a joué un
rôle très important mais vous voyez bien
pourquoi c'était une une consécration
parce que au fond il y avait deux thèses
la première c'était que on pouvait
gagner en étant inféodés ni à un bord ni
à l'autre
et deuxièmement c'est pas parce que vous
n'avez pas de majorité avant l'élection
que vous n'en aurez pas après j'ai passé
toute la campagne de 2010 est tous vos
confrères journalistes me disais mais
monsieur bayrou d'accord vous pouvez
être élu d'accord y'a les sondages pour
être élu mais vous aurez pas de majorité
vous n'avez pas de député sortant et je
leur disais
mais les français savent très bien ce
qu'ils font s'il met lisent ils
donneront une majorité et on a prouvé
avec en amérique celle de lundi 7 que
c'était en effet les français étaient
cohérents dans leurs choix et qu'on
pouvait donc changer le paysage qu'on
n'était pas obligé d'être prisonnier de
toutes les bêtises qu'on nous raconte
depuis des années est-ce que
la satisfaction d'avoir fait changer la
société
compense la déception de jamais avoir
été élu président jusque là jusque là
très bonne très bonne expression
oui pour ça que c'est formidable
engagement citoyen le militantisme tout
c'est tout c'est toutes ces choses là
oui on peut on peut jouer un rôle
décisif dans le destin d'un pays où
important dans le destin d'un pays sans
être
proclamé chef
ça m'importe peu d'être numéro un
pourvu
que je sois égal
comme tous les français comme tous les
citoyens français
savent bien qu'il faut des chefs et je
le crois et je pense que c'est
indispensable
et cependant nous sommes responsables
sommes coresponsables
citoyens ça veut dire ça ça veut dire je
ne suis pas un sujet je suis pas là pour
vous obéir je suis là parce que je
construis quelque chose avec vous et que
je vous délègue une part de ma
responsabilité
comprenez ce que cela signifie
encore une fois vous avez compris j'aime
pas être soumis mais je pense que si on
peut déclencher quelque chose de majeur
pour le monde quel on appartient ça vaut
la peine
merci françois bayrou
merci à vous
[Musique]